Helikopter - offensichtlich des Tages
eins geworden mit einem riesigen
Arganöl Sänger Banku
hallo Jana gurrt - der Idiot jeder neue
Bote kann einfach mein Hindi Scapa
zu jung und dann werde ich Joey kaput [ __ ]
und
dann kam etwas Verstand Mohammed
ausgestrahlt  ein Hindi-Dermabrush-Spiel
wurde zu einer Kiste, als er mich lärmte und er
hustete, fuhr er fort, nein, ich bin
schon gut, sang als äh, nein, ich war gerade
mit dem Touchscreen essen, ich will
keine Zwiebeln, Absichten und beendete die
SMS-Schlange  Ja, ich wusste nicht, dass Miami ein
Stutfohlen in Chamonix hat, weil es meine Wut
gegen mich hat und am besten mit
Ärger